But that's not
the Bible that came before you all.
Jesus is God. The go the Christian
belie.
So the whole point of Jesus coming into
the world is
>> before you tell us why Jesus came to the
world did not know the Bible Jesus said
that I can't do nothing by myself
whatever the so that's called submission
because why he submitted whatever the
father tells me okay also Jesus in the
Bible said he will submit he will
surrender and is the word that
>> submit he will also uh no no I know the
word I know he'll be subordinate in
Corinthian You will subordinate
subordinate father. Yes. Subordinate.
Understand that. But it's called sub.
It's not every father
>> because every father was Joseph cap.
>> No. To Joseph.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No. No. Christian. No. No.
No. No. No. I'll give you the Bible.
>> I did not read it from a script. I
>> No. No. Here. I have the Bible here.
>> Yeah. They went to Jerusalem.
>> No. But he was on the account.
>> No, that's not the one I'm talking
about. This is not the one I'm talking
about. Is it Corinth?
For instance,
>> okay, I've shown you where Jesus he will
submit to the father.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, that's not a problem. But
>> I'm saying when you finish, we'll let
that talk.
>> Of course. The nature of your
discussion. So what I'm showing you that
he did submit to God according to God's
teaching. Now you went off, you start
talking about Jesus is God. God does not
submit to Noah. Everyone submit to God.
If God submit to someone else, he cannot
be the same God who does not submit to
no one and everything submit to him. Is
a logical rational.
>> So why we going to utilize our
>> Let me tell you, let me tell you why
Jesus came. Jesus came.
>> I'll be right.
>> And get my coffee. Just hold it.
>> No, no.
God is also
And so he provided a way of
>> yeah he provided a way of by sending
Jesus which is God
to live perfectly under the Lord
and then to be without the without the
shedding of blood says no forgiveness.
So it's a story of love which is a story
of deliverance. So Jesus came, we said
Jesus came because you and I we have
sins and we cannot approach God directly
to our sins. What about the people
before Jesus? In the Old Testament, God
said that in the Bible that if you
commit sin and you refer to God and you
do righteous deeds, you will live
eternally. So therefore in the in the
Old Testament, there's nowhere where God
was teaching the people. You have to
believe in the rather the human
sacrifice is a paganism practice. Okay.
Also in the Bible, yes, there's a
sacrifice sheep because in even Islam,
if you sacrifice sheep for the sake of
Allah is an act of worship. You're not
making the sheep to take your sins. So
again, you claiming that Jesus came to
die for our sins, it goes clearly
against the teaching of the Old
Testament because the Old Testament
here, let me show you of God. Let me
show you the s.
>> Yeah, that's what Paul That's what Paul
teach you. But let me show you. No, it's
the lamb of God who takes away the sins
of the world.
>> Okay, let me show you in the Bible
giving you other things.
>> I'm sure. No, no, it's not. It is no
it's pointing to the Messiah.
>> The Old Testament teaches you
>> tells you and the new fulfills.
>> Okay. But the Old Testament teaches you
if you commit an evil sin and you repent
to God and you do righteous action, you
don't have to believe no one sins.
Simple. Good deeds. Here, I'm going to
show you. 53 before I read Isaiah 53.
Let me read it back to you. It's a whole
thing in context.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You can read the context
here.
>> Okay. Let me say here.
>> The soul whose sins shall die.
>> Absolutely.
>> The son shall not bear the guilt of the
father.
>> Right.
>> So Jesus should not bear no se.
>> Okay.
>> Nor the father bear the guilt of the
son. The righteousness of the righteous
should be upon himself. He's general for
everyone. Okay. and the e the wickedness
of the wicked shall be upon himself.
>> But if a wicked man from all his sins
which he has committed keeps all my
status and does what is lawful and
right, he shall surely live. He should
not die.
>> Yeah.
>> None of the none of the transgressions
which he has committed shall be
remembered against him because of the
righteousness which he has done. He
shall live. This exactly what in the
Quran Allah mentioned in the Quran if
you do evil acts and you repent to Allah
and you do righteous good deeds. You do
righteous good deeds and you turn back
to Allah subhana wa ta'ala Allah will
forgive your sins.
>> Allah is able to wait before wait
>> where is it?
>> Yeah. Put me
>> where is it? Where is it?
>> You're doing very well.
>> Thank you.
>> I'll give you Allah cannot forgive
anybody's sins. He's not a father of
anybody. He did not love anybody before
die for anybody. Before we address it,
before we digress,
>> before we digress, but let us come to
that. So, so here clearly he teaches us
in the Old Testament likewise that if
you commit sin and you do righteous good
deeds, you enter paradise. So, no one
should die for no one. that there's the
teacher in the Old Testament and it's
very interesting because taking it out
of context
>> you have to read the whole of the Bible
>> you have to read the whole Bible no
>> what we what I found funny sorry I
didn't mean the Bible is funny what I
find funny is the response so you're
saying we can't derive a context from
that passage
>> no because you you have to take it in
connection with all the passages that
speak to this issue
>> all right so read that verse and then
you tell us explanation Yeah, here here
you you tell us what is the context
here. I I'm not wearing a
>> Okay. What I would say to you the most,
you know, I will say to you, look look
yeah, someone dying for your sins is a
paganism practice. The Old Testament
never teach that. Okay. Who came? Who
came? Who came? No, no, no. Not die for
your sins. Okay.
Now, I want to focus on one thing which
is very important. Yeah.
>> Does God have a God?
>> Of course not.
>> So, if G is God, you should have no God.
I don't know how you're thinking about
it, but there's one God.
>> There's one God in the but in the Bible.
Jesus said, "I'm going to my God and
your God." to my father and your father.
So Jesus have a God. And you just told
me you just told me. Sorry. You just You
just told me God have no God.
>> What you looking for?
>> Sister.
>> You just told me have no god. But Jesus
have got
>> Jesus has nothing to do
>> and the Bible said he have got
>> he has nothing to do
>> now. May Allah guide you to Islam.
>> Thank you. I have
>> take care of this. All right. Take care.
>> You see this may Allah guide you to
Islam because there's a there's a day of
reckoning.
Allah is the adversary of Jesus. The
enemy could Jesus couldn't even
Jesus could even help himself. He got
beat up by the Romans.
>> You have been
>> Jesus got beat by the God. got beat up
by the Romans. Imagine you worship God,
got beat up by the Romans. It's very bad
for you on day of judgment.
>> Yeah.
>> Alhamdulillah.